[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
über dichter und marietta slomka
guten abend weihnachten will man den
leuten noch lassen vor silvester kommen
dann die einschränkungen das ist in
einem satz die beschlussvorlage für die
morgige bund länder runde die gute alte
corona mpk man kennt sie ja hinlänglich
nur jetzt halt mit kanzler scholz dass
ein solches treffen dringend nötig sein
das ist ein plan braucht und die politik
sich nicht in die weihnachtsferien
verabschieden kann wurde auch von der
wissenschaft sehr deutlich signalisiert
der von der bundesregierung neu
geschaffen expertenrat sieht
handlungsbedarf und zwar besser heute
als morgen was sony konsole türkisch
macht dazu gleich noch ein gespräch doch
zunächst berichtet christian hübscher
welche pläne die politik hat
seit tagen sinken die infektionszahlen
doch die entspannung dürfte trügerisch
sein denn omikron nimmt längst anlauf
die neue variante die noch ansteckender
sein soll jetzt vor diese fünfte welle
kommen so lautet der politische wettlauf
bundeskanzler scholz gerade auf
staatsbesuch in rom bereitet die
deutschen zu hause auf neue
einschränkungen vor erstmals auch für
geimpfte und genießen mit dem
ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten wird jetzt gerade
vorbereitet eine entscheidung die morgen
zu treffen ist sie wird sicherlich
private kontakte auch von geimpften noch
mal etwas mehr zusammenfassen was scholz
meint und was morgen hier beim bund
länder treffen beschlossen werden könnte
geht deutlicher aus ersten
beschlussvorlage hervor die durchs
regierungsviertel kreisen ab dem 28
dezember werden private zusammenkünfte
von geimpften und genesenen nur noch mit
maximal zehn personen erlaubt heißt es
da doch eben erst in acht tagen wartet
omikron also brav bis nach weihnachten
bloß keinem das fest verderben so klingt
es heute aus der politik wir wollen die
einladungen die jetzt ausgesprochene
sind vor weihnachten nicht ad acta legen
aber eben nach weihnachten soll noch
weiter reduziert werden wissen auch aus
der vergangenheit dass das
weihnachtsfest nicht der pandemie
treiber ist wenn wir mit den familien
zusammenkommen zur kaffeetafel oder zum
abendessen dann ist das auch in diesem
jahr möglich aber die große silvester
sause wird es nicht geben können
keine großen partys kein feuerwerk
silvester dieses jahr wird wohl so klein
wie silvester letztes jahr scholz und
die länderchefs werden angetrieben von
der wissenschaft so warnt der neue
expertenrat gestern vor einer
explosionsartigen verbreitung durch die
omikron variante dabei wäre ein
relevanter teil der bevölkerung
zeitgleich erkrankt und oder in
quarantäne glaube man muss sich einfach
darauf vorbereiten dass das ein sehr
ähnliches virus ist in der krankheits
stärke in den krankheitsverlauf aber
sehr viel deutlich schneller übertragbar
ist ab dem 28
dezember sollen auch clubs und
diskotheken geschlossen werden
großveranstaltungen ab dann nur noch
ohne zuschauer stattfinden der
gesundheitsexperte der grünen würde
gerne noch weiter gehen schreibt heute
ein mögliches szenario wäre ein gut
geplanter lockdown anfang januar denn
hier droht uns auch gerade
beispielsweise im bereich der kritischen
infrastruktur im großen umfang ein
personalausfall durch symptomatische
erkrankungen wir tun gut daran im moment
nichts auszuschließen und uns eher auf
eine sehr dramatische situation
konsequent vorzubereiten da wird er
sichtbar der konflikt zwischen grünen
und liberalen in der ampelkoalition
die fdp weiß aber dass viele menschen in
unserem land sich vor einem neuerlichen
lockdown fürchten pauschale schließungen
von schulen oder
des handels
sollten immer nur die ultima ratio
bleiben es geht sich vorzubereiten auf
eine womöglich kritische phase der
pandemie wo impfen und postern alleine
nicht mehr helfen werden
und aus bedienen zugeschaltet ist uns
der leiter der im forschung des charité
leif erik sander guten abend herr
professor sander interessen sie sind ja
teil der experten bis 69 expertenrats
der bundesregierung und sagen ganz klar
also nur boostern und zeit lang sah es
so aus als würde die politik für
allerdings nur auf dass boost ansetzen
das wird jetzt bei amica nicht mehr
reichen ja zunächst mal ist so dass die
omikron variante sich weniger gut durch
die antikörper neutralisieren lässt die
wir mit einer impfung ausbilden und was
wir gesehen haben und das ist positiv
das eine booster impfung also diese
dritte impfung dass die wirklichen sehr
guten und sehr positiven effekt dass mal
die gute nachricht die man mitnehmen
kann man sieht auch dass menschen dann
wieder besser auch geschützt sind vor
infektionen mit der omicron variante
allerdings und das zeigen viele analysen
die auch der expertenrat angesehen hat
das boostern alleine wird vermutlich
nicht ausreichen um diese welle an
infektionen die auf einen zukommt jetzt
vollständig aufzuhalten welches szenario
befürchten sie denn das dann so viele
leute sind quarantäne sind mit oder ohne
symptomen das praktisch das öffentliche
leben zum stillstand kommt mehr oder
weniger weil diese variante so irrsinnig
ansteckend ist ja da haben sie recht die
wir wissen natürlich noch nicht alles es
ist immer noch relativ früh das was wir
bisher an daten kennen sieht allerdings
jetzt auch nicht so gut aus diese
variante ist eben sehr ansteckend
verbreitet sich deutlich schneller als
alle bisherigen varianten bringt damit
eine ganz neue dimension in die premiere
eine ganz andere geschwindigkeit rein
das boostern wie gesagt hat einen
positiven effekt wir wissen noch nicht
allzu viel über die krankheit schwerer
allerdings müssen wir erst mal davon
ausgehen dass personen die weder geimpft
noch genesen sind ungefähr genauso stark
erkranken können wie an den vorherigen
varianten und wenn das alles ganz
schnell geht und alles gleichzeitig
auftritt dann kann es natürlich eine
situation geben wie zum beispiel das
auch in südafrika teilweise erlebt wird
teilweise auch schon england erlebt wird
dass sehr viele menschen einfach
gleichzeitig erkranken in ein quarantäne
müssen und dann können sie in betrieb
einfach sei es im krankenhaus oder in
einen anderen bereich schlecht
aufrechterhalten ja das wird ja aus
langen auch schon berichtet dass dann
doch noch den rettungssanitäter fehlen
sie sprachen gerade an wir wissen noch
nicht so viel über die schwere aber das
ist nicht also die schwere der
erkrankung wir wissen omikron ist so
kann stecken aber es gibt
unterschiedliche aussagen dazu ob es
gleich etwas milder ist oder sogar noch
schwerer erkranken lässt oder heftiger
erkranken lässt als täter was ist denn
da bisher erkenntnisstand der
wissenschaft wie gesagt es ist noch
relativ früh und wir haben noch nicht so
viele daten die wir uns ansehen können
was wir wissen ist dass in südafrika und
ich war grad heute wieder im gespräch
mit kolleginnen und kollegen aus
südafrika in südafrika ist es so die
haben drei sehr schlimme wellen hinter
sich da sind also viele mensch wenn
nicht sogar alle schon mindestens einmal
infiziert gewesen viele viele menschen
sind auch gestorben in südafrika das
heißt infektionen die dort jetzt
stattfinden finden hauptsächlich in
einer immunen bevölkerung statt also
eine bevölkerung die schon einen
gewissen immunschutz hat was sie
beobachten zum glück ist das eben die
krankheit die schwere der erkrankung in
südafrika nicht so ausgeprägt ist aber
in bestimmten hot spots zum beispiel in
london sehen wir dort steigen auch die
krankenhausaufnahmen wieder und wir
haben eben in deutschland das problem
dass sehr viele menschen eben weder
geimpft noch genießen sind also
überhaupt keine immunität haben also
nicht diese situation wie in südafrika
und da steht eben zu befürchten dass die
krankheit schwere genau so ausgeprägt
ist wie zum beispiel mit der delta
variante war auch die die gewässer sind
fragen sich also wie lange hält dieser
booster muss es in drei vier monaten
dann spritze nummer 4 bekommen oder wie
wird das weitergehen was ihre
einschätzung als als impfstoff forscher
eine wichtige frage das was wir sehen
konnten in unseren analysen und was auch
andere gruppen gezeigt haben ist dass
diese booster impfung wirklich
qualitativ einen vorteil bringt die art
der antikörper die nach der booster
impfung gebildet sind die sind noch
besser nachgeschärft die können auch die
omikron variante
neutralisieren allerdings wissen wir
nicht wie haltbar sind diese antikörper
können die wieder etwas ab sinken was
bedeutet das für die empfänglichkeit
diese daten werden in den nächsten
wochen reinkommen aktuell wissen wir
aber die booster bringen wirklichen
schutz die bringen qualitativen
unterschied und deswegen kann man nur
appellieren dass jetzt wirklich ganz
massiv zu beschleunigen weiterzumachen
gerade menschen die ein risiko haben
schwerer zu erkranken also älter sind
oder vorerkrankungen haben wirklich
lassen sich in den nächsten tagen
boostern das schützt auf jeden fall zum
gewissen grad vor der omicron variante
aber wie sie ja auch sagten dass
russland allein werde nicht reichen und
hat ja die politik vorschläge vorgelegt
die ab 28 greifen sondern darüber wird
morgen gesprochen aber sie liegen ja
schon auf dem tisch das ist ab 28
kontakt beschränkungen gibt hat omikron
so viel zeit oder lässt angekommen und
so viel zeit aus ihrer persönlichen
sicht ich glaube der expertenrat hat ja
in dieser einstimmigen stellungnahme
relativ klar ausgedrückt wir haben es
hier mit einer neuen dimension zu tun es
gibt bisher nicht dagewesene
verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit
teilweise in england beobachtet man
verdopplung zeiten von zwei bis drei
tagen auch in deutschland ist davon
auszugehen dass wir in einem ähnlichen
bereich vielleicht etwas langsamer
liegen das heißt viel zeit bleibt nicht
deswegen ist es auch sehr begrüßenswert
dass morgen politischen
entscheidungsträgern zusammenkommen und
darüber diskutieren welche maßnahmen
gemeinsam mit helfen können diese welle
einzudämmen und das das müssen wir
abwarten ich denke es sind verschiedene
maßnahmen zusammen notwendig das ist
schon relativ klar dass boostern ist
eins davon herr professor sondern dank
für das gespräch
was inter will haben wir aufgezeichnet
die reaktionen auf die warnungen der
wissenschaft fallen bekanntlich
unterschiedlich aus ein bisschen so als
würde eine tsunami-warnung heraus rollen
und während die meisten sich in
sicherheit bringen wollen bleiben andere
kopfschüttelnd am strand stehen welle
welche welle hier ist doch nur wasser
dieser teil der bevölkerung bekommt
vergleichsweise große aufmerksamkeit
auch weil der protest laut und politisch
gut organisiert ist dagegen macht sich
der große teil der gesellschaft der
korona ernst nimmt und eindämmen will
weit weniger bemerkbar doch da scheint
sich gerade etwas zu ändern gestern gab
es zum beispiel in österreich in wien
einen großen lichterzug unter dem motto
yes we can
zehntausende gedachten so der coronado
auch in deutschland lässt sich ein
solches erwachen der zivilgesellschaft
beobachten
auch und gerade in sachsen berichtet
thomas bärsch
mit den kerzen die hier einwohner von
ebersbach und neugersdorf in der lausitz
mit ihrer bürgermeisterin entzünden
gedenken sie der korona toten und an die
menschen die sich der pandemie täglich
in den weg stellen doch in diesen zeiten
ist ihnen auch wichtig wer hier kerzen
anzündet immer wieder hatten zuletzt im
skeptiker und corona demonstranten vor
sächsischen rathaustüren grablichter
platziert demonstranten denen die
bürgermeisterin das feld nicht
überlassen will bei allem verständnis
die situation ist keine einfache und es
sind sicherlich auch viele fehler
gemacht worden auch von der politik in
den vergangenen monaten aber das täuscht
doch nicht darüber hinweg dass wir
tatsächlich diese schwierige pandemie
haben das wird tatsächlich viele
menschen verloren haben die gestorben
sind es ist aber auch ein aufbegehren
gegen demonstranten die das bild in
sachsen prägen gegen sogenannte
spaziergänger gegen fackelträger vor
politiker häusern oder gegen
hinrichtungs fantasien im internet
auch in bautzen gingen heute abend
wieder hunderte auf die straße doch
diesmal setzte die stadt etwas entgegen
an häuserwände geworfene bilder die vor
augen führen sollen was sich täglich im
städtischen krankenhaus abspielt eine
botschaft an die spaziergänger ob sie
auf der straße ankommt
das weiß ich nicht aber was sie merken
ist dass es gegenwind gibt und das muss
sein es ist viel zu spät auch weil es
kein gegenwind gegeben hat ist das ja so
groß geworden fast 15.000 menschen
machen inzwischen in einer bonner
erklärung deutlich dass sie hinter den
corona maßnahmen stehen und auch dass
sie damit in deutschland immer noch eine
mehrheit vertreten auch die bautzener
musiker von silbermond haben
unterzeichnet ihre antwort auf die frage
warum sich diese mehrheit oft so
zurückhält ganz ehrlich wenn der mob von
50 weiß nicht schwarz angezogen den
leuten durch so eine nebenstraße von
bautzen ziehen und irgendwelche parolen
rufen dann verstehe ich dass das die
leute in ihrem eigenen zuhause angst
haben und das darf nicht sein
es ist der laute protest der den leisen
übertönt und der dazu auch die
aufmerksamkeit auf saugt medien und
politik schauten auf die falschen schon
seit beginn da sagt der politologe das
mache es der zivilgesellschaft schwer
ja die resonanz in den medien ist
bisweilen sehr gering gewesen es war
immer das interesse auf peggy da stärker
am anfang wenn man das mal nimmt als
beispiel das größtes beispiel da hat man
doch sehr genau hingeguckt und hat sich
auf die sorgen dieser menschen berichtet
die politik hat den dialog mit china
gesucht und nicht mit der
zivilgesellschaft die dagegen aufsteht
und das ist natürlich ein riesen problem
weil dadurch zivilgesellschaft ein
bisschen unsichtbar wird aber nicht
heute wie in der lausitz ging am abend
auch im erzgebirgischen freiberg
menschen auf die straße mit einem
statement pro impfungen angemeldet
corona konformen kleinen zugelassenen
gruppen der spaziergänger protest
hingegen hielt sich hier heute in
grenzen
und jetzt macht erstmal keine server
richter weiter da bleiben wir bei der
pandemie in der eu steht jetzt ein
fünfter corona impfstoff zur verfügung
die eu kommission hat das vakzin der us
firma nova wachs zugelassen ab januar
soll es ausgeliefert werden es handelt
sich um den ersten protein basierten
impfstoff bestehend aus künstlich
hergestellten spike proteinen durch die
impfung bildet der körper antikörper und
t-zellen gegen diese proteine wie gut
der impfstoff gegen die omikron variante
wirkt ist noch unklar
frauen sind von longo wird offenbar
häufiger betroffen als männer das geht
aus einer studie der uni mainz hervor
dennoch klagen 46 prozent der weiblichen
genesenen über langfristige beschwerden
bei den männlichen sind es 35 prozent
insgesamt berichten fast 30 dass sie
nach der erkrankung ihre ursprüngliche
leistungsfähigkeit nicht wieder erreicht
hätten und mehr als 40 leiden auch sechs
monate nach ihrer genesung noch an
müdigkeit
gedächtnisstörungen oder kurzatmigkeit
der
bundestagsabgeordnete bijan djir sarai
soll neuer fdp generalsekretär werden
parteichef lindner hat den 45-jährigen
für den posten vorgeschlagen gewählt
werden solle auf dem bundesparteitag im
kommenden frühling schwerpunkt des
gebürtigen iraners war zuletzt die
außenpolitik er folgt auf volker wissing
der ins bundeskabinett gewechselt ist
als neuer verkehrsminister
russland hat zwei deutsche diplomaten
ausgewiesen damit reagiert moskau auf
die ausweisung zweier russischer
diplomaten aus deutschland
hintergrund ist das urteil im
sogenannten tiergarten nord ein berliner
gericht hatte einen russen zu
lebenslanger haft verurteilt der 2009 10
einen georgier getötet haben soll
drahtzieher des mordes war laut den
richtern die russische regierung die das
opfer als staatsfeind und terrorist
einstufte moskau bestreitet jede
verwicklung
chile hat einen neuen präsidenten den
jüngsten in der geschichte des landes
überraschend deutlich gewann der frühere
studentenführer gabriel boris stichwahl
gegen den rechtspopulisten cast mit
knapp 56 prozent der stimmen der 35
jährige will mit dem neoliberalen
wirtschaftssystem der pilot diktatur
brechen außerdem verspricht der ein
besseres bildungs und gesundheitssystem
ganzer stolz war heute ja zu besuch in
rom dass er der italienischen regierung
so rasch seine aufwartung macht
unterstreicht die gewachsene bedeutung
die italien für die deutsche
europapolitik hat das liegt nicht nur
daran dass beim wichtigsten partner
frankreich im frühjahr
präsidentschaftswahlen anstehen und man
nicht weiß wie das ausgehen wird und mit
welchen folgen für europa zum anderen
hat italien politisch und wirtschaftlich
schwer aufgeholt stabil regiert vom
europafreundlichen ex ezb-chef mario
draghi das treffen in rom hat andreas
postel beobachtet
die stippvisite in rom dauert nicht mal
zwei stunden die korona lage lässt er
nicht zu aber für uns stolz das merkt
man ist der antrittsbesuch bei mario
draghi wichtig wir müssen
und werden die korona pandemie gemeinsam
bekämpfen und das bedeutet dass wir es
schaffen müssen unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger zu impfen italien hat da das will
ich ausdrücklich sagen eine sehr
vorbildliche impfquote erreicht und
einen großen teil seiner bürgerinnen und
bürger ein und zwei mal bereits geimpft
lob aus deutschland das ist italien
nicht gewohnt und überhaupt seitdem
angela merkel sich in rom mit einer
liebeserklärung verabschiedet hat wird
hier mit spannung erwartet wie
deutschland sich in zukunft verhalten
wird bundeskanzler scholl signalisiert
zusammenarbeit und kündigt einen
bilateralen aktionsplan mit italien an
es ist so dass wir entschieden haben das
jetzt zu machen und damit anzufangen
unsere regierungen arbeiten zu lassen
dass da etwas gutes frei heraus kommt
das auch in seiner konkreten so ist dass
wir sehr präzise verabredungen treffen
das klingt recht nüchtern im vergleich
zum italienisch-französischen pomp mit
dem vor drei wochen in rom einen vertrag
zur tiefgreifenden zusammenarbeit dieser
beiden länder unterzeichnet wurde dafür
schob sich was im machtgefüge europas
und olaf scholz will aus der achse ein
dreieck machen bei europäischer
verteidigung migration und
stabilitätspakt mal sehen mario draghi
jedenfalls agiert aus einer gewissen
position der stärke dank seines
reformkurses verzeichnet italien in
diesem jahr wachstumsprognosen von über
wir wollen die zusammenarbeit in
wissenschaft technologie und forschung
verstärken ich denke dabei an projekte
von gemeinsamen europäischen interesse
in bereichen die für uns in zukunft
entscheidend sind die wasserstoff
mikroelektronik und batterien für
elektroautos
wie eng deutschland italien und
frankreich zusammenhängen zeigt ein
blick nach turin stammsitz der
traditionsreichen fiat automobilwerke
seit anfang des jahres ist vier teil des
landes trug eine fusion mit dem
französischen psa konzern zu dem auch
opelt deutschland gehört fiat vorstand
olivier francois hat sich ehrgeizige
ziele gesetzt den neuen fiat 500 gibt es
nur noch elektrisch bei
batterieherstellung und ladennetz
fordert er von europa unterstützung
jede regierung spielt eine entscheidende
rolle sowohl deutschland als auch
italien und frankreich um die
autohersteller beim umbau zu
unterstützen
in rom haben sich olaf scholz und der
italienische premier heute verabredet zu
gemeinsamen regierungskonsultationen im
neuen jahr wird corona irgendwann vorbei
ist italien brauche deutschland und
deutschland rohre italien
wird jedenfalls interessant sein ob man
da auch finanzpolitisch auf einen nenner
kommt womit hörern nächsten thema wären
keine selber ja als ehemaliger ezb-chef
dürfte mario draghi heute bei dieser
meldung aufgehorcht haben joachim nagel
wird neuer präsident der bundesbank als
nachfolger von jens weidmann der galt ja
als scharfer kritiker der lockeren
geldpolitik im euroraum frank wittmann
in frankfurt was ist denn vom neuen zu
erwarten na ja die hoffnung schwingt
natürlich mit dass joachim nagel auf der
europäischen ebene ein glücklicheres
händchen haben wird als sein vorgänger
wenn es um steigende zinsen oder ein
einbremsen der inflation ging schien
jens weidmann zuletzt isoliert nagel
soll in guter bundesbank tradition
wieder für mehr stabilität und einfluss
sorgen der neue finanzminister begrüßt
die personalie ich bin sicher dass
joachim nagel in genau dieser
einschätzung auch die deutsche
bundesbank positionieren wird und
deshalb ist das eine gute besetzung ein
gutes signal an die deutsche bevölkerung
joachim nagel sozialdemokrat studierter
volkswirt ist vom fach langjähriger
experte mit 17 jahren bundesbank
erfahrung zuletzt gehörte der der
führungsetage der bank für
internationalen zahlungsausgleich an die
als zentralbank der zentralbanken gilt
nicht mit 5 prozent aber doch mit
deutlich mehr als drei prozent
geldentwertung rechnet die bundesbank im
übrigen auch im kommenden jahr dass die
inflationsrisiken bleiben beschäftigte
den dax heute aber nicht so stark wie
die immer schnellere ausbreitung des
omikron virus in der folge verlor das
aktienbarometer heute deutlich fast 300
punkte oder 1,9 prozent
nach der geburt eines kindes soll ein
elternteil das recht auf zwei wochen
bezahlten urlaub bekommen das hat
bundesfamilienministerin spiegel in der
rheinischen post angekündigt außerdem
wolle sie mehr elterngeld monate
ermöglichen für paare die sich die
elternzeit aufteilen auch menschen die
einen angehörigen pflegen sollen besser
unterstützt werden mit einer ähnlichen
leistung wie das elterngeld
im fall der chinesischen tennisspielerin
rang zwei gibt es eine neue wendung in
einem interview sagte sie sie habe
niemals behauptet von einem prominenten
politiker sexuell missbraucht worden zu
sein die post von anfang november sei
missverstanden worden auch könne sie
sich in peking frei bewegen die damen
tennis organisation wta zeigte sich
trotz dieser äußerungen besorgt um die
35 jährige
tagelang monsunregen hat den malaysia
schwere überschwemmungen ausgelöst dabei
kamen mindestens sieben menschen ums
leben die fluten rissen ganze häuser mit
tausende menschen mussten aus fahrzeugen
und gebäuden gerettet werden
zehntausende haben nun in
notunterkünften aus weil noch dutzende
menschen vermisst werden dürfte die
opferzahlen noch steigen
nicht nur akute flutkatastrophen sind
zerstörerisch das stetige steigen der
meeresspiegel ist jan mindestens genauso
bedrohlich man konnte es nur lange zeit
besser übersehen der klimawandel macht
auch vom paradies keinen halt die
session etwa mit ihren weltberühmten
stränden doch diese perfekte werbe
kulisse wird immer weniger sie
verschwindet zentimeter für zentimeter
normen odenthal hat dort einen mann
getroffen der um jedes sandkorn kämpft
im großen bilderbuch der erde finden
sich die seychellen auf den schönsten
seiten der himmel ist blau das wasser
klar der sand weißer ein paradies aus
115 inseln
victoria buddha lang 67 kennt fast alle
von ihnen er ist ein mann mit einer
mission victoria will sein inselparadies
retten für die zukunft
wichtig es geht nicht nur um die
seychellen es geht um den ganzen
planeten und die kinder helfen mit genau
wir alten haben in der vergangenheit
viel falsch gemacht die junge generation
hat das begriffen und kann es jetzt
besser machen als wir
mit einer schulklasse pflanzt victoria
mangroven deren wurzeln sollen das land
vor erosion schützen denn der steigende
meeresspiegel nagt
mir gefällt die arbeit und wenn ich
später mal wieder her komme werde ich
sicher den erfolg sehen
es macht ja auch spaß ich arbeite lieber
hier als in der schule zu sitzen
klimawandel ist auf den seychellen kein
abstraktes problem umspült vom indischen
ozean zählt jeder zentimeter steigenden
wassers küstenstraßen mussten schon
verlegt werden häuser aufgegeben und
mancher idyllischen strand mit
betonklötzen und steinen befestigt was
jedoch neue schwierigkeiten bringt weiß
viktoria
meeresschildkröten müssen eigentlich
weiter rauf auf den strand um ihre eier
zu legen aber die steine versperren
ihnen den weg auf halber strecke das ist
ein großes problem wenn sich die
schildkröten nicht mehr frei bewegen
können
viele der tiere sind ohnehin vom
aussterben bedroht die seychellen für
sie ein letzter zufluchtsort noch der
klimawandel und seine folgen ein
globales phänomen die seychellen sehen
sich dabei als opfer die großen
industrienationen als verursacher doch
unschuldig ist wohl keiner denn auch der
tourismus trägt zu den problemen bei
die ganze entwicklung kam für die
seychellen sehr schnell man hat aber
übersehen was mit unserer kultur unserer
umwelt der biodiversität passiert die
müssen wir um jeden preis bewahren wir
müssen dafür 150 jahre vorausdenken aber
heute schon handelt
victoria hat für seine mühen viele
auszeichnungen bekommen ein pionier ein
urgestein seiner enkelin zeigt der
pflanzen tiere die schätze der
seychellen ein großvater der inspiriert
ob sie auch mal sowas machen möchte
wieder oper
machte das gut
na dann weiter so victoria
eine ausführliche reportage unseres
korrespondenten über die bedrohten
inseln im indischen ozean finden sie in
unserer mediathek und hier geht es jetzt
erst mal weiter mit dem montagskino und
der letzten blick auf diesen nachrichten
tag hat dann christoph wehrmann gegen
20.42 morgen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend in die woche vor weihnachten
sind wir mit ruhigem wetter gestartet
und das verdanken wir dem hoch anni auch
in den nächsten tagen bleibt es bei uns
recht ruhig es gibt häufig sonnenschein
aber auch mal nebel und hochnebel und
fast keinen niederschlag nachts wird es
richtig frostig über den schnee flächen
am alpenrand sinken die werte in den
strengen frost von minus 12 grad sonst
liegen die temperaturen bei 0 bis -7
grad dazu ist es häufig klar es bildet
sich auch mal nebel und hochnebel im
nordosten sind die wolkenfelder etwas
dichter und die richtung erzgebirge kann
es auch mal ein bisschen schneien
schneegriesel gibt es dann auch morgen
ab und zu im nordosten denn nordöstlich
der elbe sind die wolken etwas dichter
in schleswig-holstein reicht vielleicht
mal für einen regenschauer sonst aber
gibt es nach nebel und hochnebel und
dunst häufig viel sonnenschein bei
temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt und
allenfalls in schleswig-holstein
klettern die werte mal bis 4 grad am
mittwoch ändert sich an diesem wetter
noch wenig der donnerstag wird dann aber
gefährlich denn wenn der regen auf den
gefrorenen boden hier in norddeutschland
fällt dann wird es spiegelglatt und so
heilig abend steigen die temperaturen
auf zwei bis zehn grad und es wird zu
weihnachten wirklich spannend und das
liegt daran dass sich die weißen
weihnachten eigentlich unter diesem tief
hier über dem norden russlands verbergen
das weihnachtstauwetter ist aber nicht
weit entfernt das liegt unter dem tief
über dem atlantik und beide kämpfen
miteinander und es ist unklar wer
gewinnen wird vielleicht aber wird es
über weihnachten im nordosten
tatsächlich für schneereichen guten
abend